hi my name is Nassim Nicholas Taleb and
I'm currently on the tangent School of
Engineering
I'm a former trader and I'm going to be
talking about how to play with
Mathematica when you want to tinker it
was probably how just use it as a play
as something for amusement and at the
same time get to get deeper and deeper
and deeper into probability problems
thank you for life
so this is 22 years ago my book dynamic
hedging using Mathematica as you can see
you've been a long way since everything
is wrong reasoning Mathematica all the
graphs and and you can see the this is
done by Mathematica it was not very
attractive at a time but it was for me
it was very attractive okay then no you
know that you could have all these
functions that we have today so I've
been living as a derivatives trader
using Mathematica but the good thing
about it is that when I got I became a
trader in my early 20s and when you
become a trader in your early 20s you
don't know a lot of theory or whatever
theory studied that schools kind of
thing you tried to forget right after
the exam so I didn't know a lot of
probability so I've picked up
probability as a French say on the top
so in other words while doing it it's a
complete different approach to
probability from the one you would get
by sitting in a classroom taking
lectures from someone who has never been
exposed to the same risks so sort of
like learning to ride a bicycle by
spending seven or eight years mean
lecture lab okay so and instead of just
being given a bicycle and falling a
couple of times so 22 years later 96
this is 2018 a new book comes out the
statistical consequence of fat tails
using Mathematica I look at the
difference you see all these look at
these grasses histogram was a
transparent part here beautiful okay is
Mathematica and not a lot of fluff not
putting a lot of fluff some coloring
here so the aesthetics have changed
greatly
and of course twenty two years from now
was the third book technical book using
Mathematica okay we're gonna look back
at this period so you know how what did
he do it this way okay so it'd be
sweetie but I don't think I think the
things have stabilized so this is what
I've been doing so now I'm gonna try to
talk about the thinker Inc aspect how
one can discover properties just using a
computer and playing with probability or
either you go to a casino become an
addicted gambler and casinos not good
enough because casino has Gaussian
payoffs but you can create on a computer
and play with all kind of non Gaussian
payoffs so the main thesis of this new
book is as follows when you go to fat
tails the properties are very different
and why are the properties different
because the law of large numbers and the
central limit theorem when they work
they work very differently from theory
you see if a mathematician dealing with
probability knows what happens at end of
one and knows that infinity we live
somewhere in between and when you live
somewhere in between there's some things
that become very weird okay there's some
payoffs that come for you you know there
are very different so I'm going to talk
about these things using of course a
method that I didn't copy from Stephen
Wolfram because I did myself as a
lecture student by opening a Mathematica
workbook and programming say okay when
you want your food you want to cooked on
a spot okay
here we're going to do something similar
but with some shortcuts so let me start
with something called commonly known as
the central limit theorem
everybody talks about central limit
theorem and you ask people to define it
they all define it properly they just
don't tell you how fast you get to
Gaussian now what is central limit let
me show you very simply let's take a
uniform distribution the thinnest tailed
distribution or the simplest one and
let's do a histogram of that
distribution okay
with nf1
look what I got should I make it bigger
window magnification a little bigger
125 okay I'm sorry
150 all right okay this is the the monte
carlo with a thousand of a uniform
distribution okay now i add two
variables and look what i got
very quickly I got a triangular
distribution because think about it you
see you have much you know you can get
one to get one it's very easy to get one
any combination half of one point five
point two one point eight it can give
you and a certain honor to you know give
you one but then to get 2.0 or zero you
see you gotta get 2.0 and zero or zero
you see so so for the sum to get so you
got a triangle very quickly and now of
course by n of six you pretty much have
a Gaussian so I'm summing up very small
number of observation and I got a
Gaussian with this is the central limit
all that very simple the condition is
that to have a finite variance iid is
recommended required sometimes right so
they have these rules and everybody in
statistics assumes that if you have an N
that is 30 or so then you can talk about
converting to a Gaussian true no you
eventually converge to a Gaussian but at
different speed for different
distributions okay and let's see how
that works was a different situation let
me take the gamma distribution okay and
let's use one that's a gamma
distribution one two
you're not in a triangle yet three six
okay it still doesn't look like a
Gaussian it skewed at six and you can't
go on eventually you will get to a
Gaussian okay rather quickly
it will start looking like a Gaussian
eventually and of course at infinity
they all look like a Gaussian now let me
take a distribution at Pareto
distribution with a tail exponent of two
and let's do the following this out
looks like not a Gaussian there's a six
for one so it looks like you always have
a very large deviation somewhere here
and if you of course asked Mathematica
to show all observations then then of
course sometimes you have the thing
going all the way here you see this is
very very compressed so you have an
outlier in that and eventually this will
become a Gaussian technically but would
take not maybe let's see a thirty what's
gonna take some time like so let me do
twenty you may take several million
observations how many million
observations aha let's stop here and go
to some a bigger problem yet then a
Gaussian have you heard of something
called law of large numbers very simple
I think ring we're gonna try this figure
out what this law of large numbers is
about okay because practically central
limit is optional for statistics okay
you could probably do without or with or
was it more complicated central limit
called generalized central limit and
it's not necessary for statistical
inference what is necessary is a lot of
large numbers okay for science you need
to another mean you agree all right so
let's let's say thanks again in a
literature you do not have any
information as to what end is required
it tells you n of 1 or n infinity
so the let's take let's now with the lnn
look at the following situation okay
there is the distribution the most
commonly known is not the Gaussian the
most commonly used is which one sorry
Pareto 80/20 simply because people talk
about it on the media that covers and
stuff like that you know it's easy to
understand 20% of the people in Italy
owned 80% of the land and so on okay
20% of programmers do 80% of the work
20% of the money in trading comes from
80% of the people and 80% from right
okay so so let's say now let's see how
that law of large number works with that
Pareto distribution 1.14 and it has a
mean thanks to Mathematica I don't have
mean is 1 over alpha minus 1 okay which
is a mean of 8.14 okay all right now
let's run an average we have 30
observation let's start with 30
observation sorry all ran the very first
oh it's is not defined okay there you go
we got a mean of 3.3 - okay I'm gonna
try again 579 we know what the real mean
is 8.1 for now what is the probability
of having a single observation at or
above the mean very low
you see these distributions are weird
most observation are below the mean you
agree okay now let's say let's look at
the thing I just wrote a paper on that
and I strange enough I mean it's like
nobody thought about it okay which tells
you the following how much more day that
you need for a potato for equivalent
various distribution the Gaussian how
much more
that you need for operator someone give
me an idea
Nutrition 5x who said more sorry
how much do you say hundred fifty more
he said how many one order of magnitude
more ten to the fifteen to get the same
error on the same mean deviation all
right okay now how do you discover that
by trying to figure out what the hell
this law of large number is okay so
let's look at the Gaussian are one
random distribution Gaussian and let's
look at the Gaussian here okay how you
converge to the mean of the Gaussian
let's make it ten thousand no no that
length da1 sorry okay look at the
Gaussian it's so smooth no distribution
not not single observation can mess it
up okay let's compare to the Prendergast
discussion has a high variance no matter
how much I raise the variance let's say
I go from five variants to 15 variance
for a Gaussian multiplying the variance
okay it delays you a little bit okay
not much okay now let's compare you know
what let me given that I don't like the
blue color that comes with Mathematica
plus style red particularly that it's
justified in this case okay
this is a lot range all okay there you
go
this is the mean for hey this is what
the mean does for an even four went to
10,000 for Pareto 80/20 okay
so it's the point is of course you go
down for one you go down a square root
of T and the other one you go down at a
very very different exponent okay so
okay now these things not now you may
tell me this is trivial mathematically
once you think about it becomes trivial
okay but you don't think of these things
when you when you do my idea skin in the
game is that you don't think there's
something I call the blue lumber the
green lumber problem and it's a Mostafa
trader the person who decided to get
rich trading green lumber so he bought
every book on green lumber you know
everything between lumber and then every
statistic on green lumber bought every
model on lumber okay he know everything
and and then he had to write a book what
I learned losing a million dollars okay
and then he reported that there was a
fellow per trader who always made money
with it and then one day he discovered
that that pit trader did not know that
green lumber was freshly cut lumber he
thought it was lumber painted green so
the thing is so from the outside what
you need to know so it doesn't mean that
the person didn't know anything it means
that from the inside by tinkering and
playing with something you get a
complete different story from the one
you have on the outside you see so so
this is why you start with probability
you play with a Monte Carlo simulator
if you don't play with a monocot assume
you'll never figure out you're going to
have a green lumber problem so and this
okay so I'm into doing this for years
and of course you start getting
intuition for example about about how
what happened to the smoothness of
random variables this is a normal
distribution using the bar chart okay
look what happens when you look at it it
is not scale invariant in a sense that
if you look at it from very far away if
you zoom in if you make it longer and
zoom in it would look smoother
you see but the distribution we had
before a fat tail distribution will
never look smooth you say it will never
looked once in a while it's gonna be a
big jump
it would never look smooth and if you
extend it it looks the same at all
scales now of course on average if you
extend it probably have a jump that goes
way above a thousand or the other one
would hardly ever go above three so
these things are visual so number one
CLT
number two ll n so you can start ranking
the speed of convergence of
distributions based on you know how how
they work and effectively you can do
analytical work and to show you how you
can join hands and work with with
Mathematica I have for every thing I
write I have something on the side
called 8 2 book where you can do
analytical work with Mathematica on the
side but it's not as much fun of course
as Monte Carlo because Monica will
surprise you you see and they had they
are beautiful functions you can use with
Mathematica that we were writing
longhand before and then of course my
guests are adding on transform
distribution you get a characteristic
function and then with that you can
invert the inverse Fourier you can do
things you can do a lot of analytical
work with with that stuff and and so so
there are a lot of you know little thing
we can do with Mathematica now let me
talk about another intuition that again
I mean so from here on I mean they have
a book mathematical book published a lot
of papers it's collection of papers so a
lot of papers and journals on
mathematical properties of fat tails
that came from very stupid observations
discovered playing simply with that you
know Monte Carlo generator ok so this is
what I owe to Mathematica but other
things something else let's talk about
the p-value problem okay the the p-value
problem is
let's say let's go back to the lecture
or some conference demo it's a p-value
problem is as follows okay
here I have correlation let me start
with correlation I have two random
variables that are completely
uncorrelated zero correlation between
the two and I have 18 variables for each
okay
you let's do it simulate it now okay
what do you expect the correlation to be
between these two variables you expect
it to be zero okay
very good let's see so let's do a a
equal random variate you pick a
distribution someone picks a
distribution sorry explanations not
exciting sorry okay so let me give you
sorry let me use the simplest okay
normal distribution sorry
known distribution and let's save 80
variable okay and be equal okay
all right now what's the correlation
between a and B okay let's see are you
sure
42%
okay okay so this is the problem of that
something that doesn't say this is very
elementary we know actually there's an
explicit distribution for this in
dimension - okay the correlation
distribution and and I mentioned end
it's called the Martian co-pastor which
is on mathematics Mathematica okay for
thin tail not for fat tail okay for
distribution or rather value in the
matrix matrix there's an expectation you
have zero but no samples should deliver
anything close to zero but as you
lengthen your sample what do you get you
approach zero at square root of n this
is well-known so let's do here a very
simple distribution of correlation now
this is really one on one and I think
Fischer knew about it hundred years ago
okay the problem is anyone who uses I
give class if someone uses any
statistical package see these packages
that have allow you to use a lot of data
automatically I mean I'm not allowed to
brutalize students or be nasty to them
but I act as if the person has committed
a huge sin if you have not written your
own equation you cannot talk about
correlation because or you have to play
with it so this is this is where you see
that that people can play with a system
okay we still have correlation now that
p-values yet okay that it's a random
variable correlation as a random
variable and let's do here table
how many let's do a thousand histogram
there you go so the collation would be
on average zero it has a distribution
okay alright people start to get it
because visibly we have test statistics
for that but now comes the current
replication crisis in psychology if you
apply the same reasoning to p-values
identical phenomena will deliver
different p-values okay you get what we
have today the replication prices with a
bonus what is the bonus that if I'm
taking the distribution of the maximum
of random variables okay let's say now I
have to choose between a lot of
correlation you see it shows a lot of
correlation then I have distribution of
the maximum school p-value hacking and I
have a a paper called on on the
properties p-value hacking so but I
discovered that dickering let's look
p-value say what that [ __ ] you p-value
that's me okay define it the random
Montecarlo and this was all over the map
okay so this year this comes from
thinking and let's see how I think it
was p-values this is the distribution of
p-values that you get from tinkering and
to speed up cell running it if the
p-value the true mean is something like
twelve fifty sixty percent of
realization will be below 0.05 on
average you've gotta get twelve on
average that's highly skewed
distribution you don't have you're gonna
get something than forty into forty some
once in a while that would bring it up
and most observations would be below the
true p-value so when I see someone was a
p-value of 0.05 I laugh because I say
okay they tried to three times I got a
point oh five the rules p-value may be
25 or not even so now I don't know if
you know what happened in psychology but
paper
don't replicate and also there's
something evidence of p-value hacking
because you look at how many papers have
p-value of 5 a huge number nothing at
p-value of 4 or 3 and then some would be
value of 1 okay now how can you remedy
this by being skeptical about any metric
and and causing fear so anything any
time you discover something you just do
immediately in Monte Carlo now I'm
facing in genetics something called the
for population test so I'm trying
someone said it paper said you want to
be the father said yes so they sent me
something with numbers ok you know so I
went and I actually posted the
Mathematica on on Twitter the for
population test the first thing you do
is you run a Monte Carlo you say how
many what's your end what's that what's
that and this is your distribution so if
your have point to your okay maybe but
if you have point one if your statistic
shows point one no try again okay or
find something else to do so this is
where the value of tinkering comes and
again it's as stupid as riding a bicycle
we're just learning you know thinking of
lectures okay keep writing in bicycles I
guess I guess I'm okay so I can keep
going okay great thanks so the okay so
let's continue now with my lecture or
from conference demo okay so you can
also play with things with Mathematica
but there are functionalities if you
want to do conventional probability
there is a big problem you've heard them
called Fifi which is or I don't know how
you pronounce it I don't think anybody
knows how to pronounce it
that coming out of the Twitter of
President Trump and there was a quiz at
the Indian Statistical Institute okay
how many
should you type before you get a coffee
fee and effectively
I just went when end you put the
transition probabilities okay and then
you get this thing of coffee fee and
then you can know how long President
Trump has to try to someone has to try
to get it again and you can mitigate it
you can make it how long someone has to
try to find a world that sounds you know
like this or you know you can make it
and that you use just a matter of
adjusting the probabilities okay so this
is there's some things you can do other
and and of course there's the the most
musil's function in Mathematica for me
to understand is of course the
Montecarlo simulator and I remember the
days when I had when you could only
randomize zero one on Excel spreadsheet
and you had to do all these
transformation to get a real
distribution and this is where you
learned probability is a box mural
transform other transform transform or
zolotarev to have a a to have a stable
distribution but and and and the
intuition you get from that is huge but
also now continuing with intuition from
Mathematica you can play with this is
the stable distribution you can play and
figure out how parameters are affected
how you can make a distribution more fat
tail no this is more more variance this
is more skewed these distribution by the
way it was impossible to work in the old
days because they don't have a density
stable distribution class only has
density supposedly for Cauchy for for
the Gaussian and for I think the levy
which is it is all here about the levy
okay
and here we can figure out how what you
fatten the tails how things are and
build intuition just by playing with
these function manipulators great
function for that what happens when when
you change the parameters of a
distribution incidentally as I
discovered once
here and I'm gonna share is that
although they say that distribution has
no has no closed-form or near close form
they are a special situation where
there's a cross form whose alpha-3 of
one and a half and the trick is a lesson
I learned is to member you to always use
fractional okay on Mathematica because
that's what you get surprises from thing
kering so this distribution the area I
function being something that
effectively among there's a lot of
function and then you can play with
functions now let's continue with with
with was with playing with with barkoff
chain and quizzes like that the the
second most important function for me
it's doubled white apples is important
can someone say why sorry
no no because because you can you can
see all the combination in front of you
so for example I do tuples tuples
there you go sorry no ABC sorry go int
you can see the combinations in front of
you and start I mean it's a brute-force
exercise or you can see it's here
exhaustive or non exhaustive okay and
then you can you can play with with with
combination random variables that's
another trick for solving problems so
you just get the intuition by brute
force via tuples and then later on start
looking at the sweet distribution to fit
it and then later on continuous
distribution and it's quite powerful
finally a trick I did you discovered in
trading is was Monte Carlo is a lot
there's a trick okay in the old days
when computers were not yet you know
computers are practically staines
designed for video games now know for
whatever it's like help us get
mathematical function faster but that's
not the purpose so but the old days it
was very hard to the numerical
integration and very hard to do Monte
Carlo
so he had to be very stingy and very
efficient today instead of having more
and more difficult equation you just buy
more computer power spends fifteen
dollars more on computer power instead
of seventy-five thousand dollars and
research money okay so something figured
out in in sampling is if say I have a
function here I have a function that
starts here and it's in a tail of
distribution so there's only three
percent of my Monte Carlo will cover
that function okay say like an option
out of money option basically three
percent of my Monte Carlo run will
affect that option so one trick where
you can use and
method with along with brute force is
you shift the distribution okay where
the center becomes at your point 102 2
standard deviations away access the
distribution I do my Monte Carlos ok
I've saved I can save instead of saving
instead of having three percent of my
observation now have 50 percent my
observation at or above that point and
then do a change of measure
probabilistic change of measure and and
and that way I get like I'm multiplying
my sample size or usually and I get a
lot more accuracy for for cheap so these
are some of the techniques that that you
can do with and you can still do it
still saves money still saved it still
okay so let me conclude and then we take
Q&A the whole thing that I can bring to
the table because you guys are more
sophisticated than me when it comes to
whatever it is okay the only thing I
know is to transfer from practice to
theory and the value of trying to
transfer transfer in that direction and
in the absence of practice and
probability you're not going to go to a
casino okay and most thing I don't have
been to a casino but you notice it's
addictive and people spend a lot of time
with casino they stop having they look
sallow and then they have like all these
marks under their eyes so it's painful
okay you just go to a cafe have a good
cappuccino and play with Mathematica and
then you make you discover properties
okay so thanks to this these intuition
now now I have a I mean I have a bunch
of petty papers on how to translate what
happens with an of a hundred this what
happened how do you compare the
solutions based on these metrics and and
of course the p-value thing also came to
me immediately I said what the [ __ ] this
sorry
what on earth of the speed all right you
hear p-values and papers what okay let
me see okay this is how they define it
you run a Monte Carlo and then you see
you know they're full of crap already
you don't have to wait for the rest okay
the replication crisis for those who
don't know is that I think only 40% of
psychology paper replicate and those
that replicate have a much weaker effect
okay they haven't tried and economics
yet but I think zero would replicate
because they use Gaussian methods and of
course the Ossian method now you can do
this in higher dimension it's in my book
I'm not here to talk about my research
I'm here to talk about how to thinker
with Mathematica thank you for listening
to me
[Applause]